there is a cameo in this film that had
more reaction than chris hemsworth's
booty let's see who you are i take off
your disguise
and flick
oh you flicked too hard damn it
should we help him then eventually great
what can you share what are you talking
about is pretty oh that came out no that
came okay that's one camera but there's
another cameo at the end brett goldstein
uh-huh yes that had the audience
out of their minds yeah what can you
share about bringing him on board are
you big ted lasso fan yes i am i
can't share much because you know that
was all kevin kevin was like hercules
how about we ask brett and you know
kevin yeah keeps his cards you know
close to the chest so like i don't want
to like
where are you pushing this what do you
want from the you know where are you
going to go with the circulars character
so we'll see but it's pretty exciting to
start opening up the world of
zeus and hercules and the greek gods
the only ones who gods care about
is themselves
so this is my vow
oh god shall die
you've said that it is better than
ragnarok you ain't wrong sir for you
what is it about this film that tops
your last you know for me ragnarok was
about it was fun it was like a good
adventure but it wasn't like the most
emotional that i wanted to see uh thor
experience and we asked ourselves what
are the thoughts what what are the
thoughts one of the thor fans
like what's gonna kind of freak them out
the most because i
love the idea of a superhero dealing
with love because you know like you know
what especially guys you know what they
were like
look kissing gross you know i was like
yeah it's got to lean really deeply into
that yeah like make it like a
melodramatic romantic love story um and
just deal with the the concept of love
for all of the characters in the film am
i uh sensing feelings
[Music]
well you're right
natalie said that you were a fan
favorite of her kids on set they were
most wowed by you she said i think taika
really impressed them a lot because he's
just so
creative and so funny they were really
blown away by him what were you doing on
saturday with the kids man i don't know
talk to them
[Laughter]
what was it i wasn't a fan favorite of
my kids when they came to see it my
daughter came on and i put her in a
scene with christian bale and arguably
the greatest actor working today and
after two takes my six-year-old walked
off and i said where you going she said
i'm done give me my money and i said no
babe you've got to do it all day she
said all day unfazed the brakes are too
short and he's by the marble machine
yeah she brought back christian bail she
walked past him and he was like hello
how are you and she goes
she walks past her she said note about
me one day one day she's gonna learn now
chris told me that he liar i can't with
you too you guys are the best chris told
me that he always thinks it's his last
go around as thor and then another
brilliant story comes along each time
i've done it i've sort of thought okay i
don't know what else i could say is this
character so what are you gonna write
for him next what would really annoy the
fans that's really the only thing that
i'm interested in what would what are
the fans don't want you just find out
what the fans don't want on reddit
and then that'll be the next thought
i mean you gave us
a challenge for me is then to make
something to make them love it what
would it be okay thor and a buddy on a
road trip to vegas fully clothed fully
clothed
and winter
sweaters christmas
christmas christmas
thor chris a chris christmas two
christmas chris pratt and thor
oh my god guys take this down star lord
thor
road trip movie christmas they've got to
get to someone to someone's house for
christmas you're making your rounds with
the hollywood christmas oh the christmas
pun you i know you need to pun and
hemsworth who's your favorite who's your
favorite all hollywood christmas
same
[Music]
you